Let's look at the same setup again, lens is a symmetric so the focal lens will
be on both sides of the lens, let's imagine that I have a 3D object on
this part of the scene here, and, the image plane is being formed on this side.
So I put an object here, basically remembering what we,
looked at in the last side, any parallel light goes through,
goes through the focal point here, continues on,
anything that goes through, the optic will point here, goes to unadulterated and
then the third line, of course, the opposite of the converse of this one,
anything that goes with the focal point will become parallel on the other side.
So in essence, these three lines, will converge at this point and this is where
the image will be formed, so this is where the image point is for this object.
So, rays from points on a plane parallel, to the lens,
focus on, a point that is far away here, and
we will actually now come up with an equation that basically connects the object
distance from the lens, to the focal length to where the image is formed.
So here, of course would be my tree again, as we've noticed, on the other side,
it'll be formed upside down, and again, just calling this distance of
the object from the lens itself to be o and the distance to the image as i.
So this is what is referred to as a lens equation, and mathematically,
basically, it's 1 over the distance of the object from the lens plus 1 over
distance of the image from the lens is equal to 1 over the focal length.